let's say that you have a cherry pie
store and you've noticed that there is
variability in the number of cherries on
each pie that you sell some pies might
have over 100 cherries while other pies
might have fewer than 50 cherries so
what you're curious about is what is the
distribution how many of the different
types of pies do you have how many pies
you have that have a lot of cherries how
many pies you have that have very few
cherries how many pies are in between
and so to do that you set up a histogram
what you do is you take each pie in your
store let's see if I can draw you draw a
pie of some kind it's a cherry pie I
don't know if this is an adequate
drawing of a pie but you take each of
the pies in your in your store and you
count the number you count the number of
cherries on it so this pie right over
here is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so you keep
counting and let's say it has 32
cherries and you do that for every buy
and then you created buckets because you
don't want to create just a graph of how
many have exactly 32 you just want to
get a general sense of things so you
create buckets of 30 you say how many
pies have between 0 and 29 cherries how
many pies have between 30 and 59
including 30 and 59 how many pies have
at least 60 and at most 89 cherries how
many pies have at least 90 and at most
119 and then how many pies have at least
120 and at most 149 and you know that
you don't have any pies that have more
than 149 cherries so this should account
for everything and then you count them
so for example you say ok 5 5 30 to 59
cherries and so we create a histogram or
you create a histogram and you make this
magenta bar go up to 5 so that's how you
would construct this histogram that's
what this pie is at different cherry
levels histogram is telling us so now
that we know how to construct it let's
see if we can interpret it based on the
information given in the histogram so
the first question is based on just this
information can you figure out the total
number of pies in your store zooming
that they're all accounted for by this
histogram and I encourage you to pause
the video and try to figure it out on
your own well what's the total number
Five's well let's see there's 5 pies
there's
five pies that have between that have
more than 30 or more and have at least
30 cherries but no more than 59 you have
eight pies in this blue bucket you have
four pies in this green bucket and then
you have what is this five no this is
three pies that have at least 120 but no
more than 149 cherries and this accounts
for all of the pies so the total number
of pies you have at the store or five
plus eight plus four plus three which is
what five plus eight is thirteen plus
four seventeen plus three is twenty so
there are 20 pies in this store then you
can ask more nuanced question what if
you wanted to know the number of pies
with more than 60 cherries the number of
pies with more than 60 so number of pies
with I'll say let's say 60 or more 60 or
more 60 or more cherries so let's think
about it well this magenta bar doesn't
apply because these all have less than
60 but all of these other bars are
counting pies that have 60 or more
cherries this is 60 289 this is 19 119
this is 120 149 so it's going to be
these eight cherries that are eight
these eight pies that are in this bucket
plus these four pies plus these three
pies so it is going to be essentially
everything but this first bucket
everything but all the pies except for
these five pies have 60 or more cherries
so it should be five less than 20 and so
let's see 8 plus 4 is 12 plus 3 is 15
which is five less than 20 so using this
histogram we can answer a really
interesting we can say well how many
more pies do we have that have 60 289
cherries than 120 to 149 cherries well
we say well we have eight pies that have
60 8960 289 cherries three that have 120
249 so we have five more pies in the
sixty to eighty nine category than we do
in the 120 to 149 category so a lot of
questions that we can start to answer
and hopefully this gives you a sense of
how you can interpret histograms